i auditioned for snl this year and then
i tested for snl and then i like even
went to this round of meetings that's
like the final thing before you get the
job and that's that it's all great it
was all wonderful and they
then cast merch is great and it's like
genuinely no hard feelings but the
the lesson is
no genuinely it's like
yeah laura michaels uh
it's cool man
yeah no i mean we are i'm not pissed at
all yeah but i i i improved my audition
that i improv the test like on the snl
stage like i was like i was like i don't
i don't write out my videos so i'm just
gonna off the cuff this and i and it got
me like all the way but then it didn't
get me the job so it's like does it work
does it not work wait i want to know
about the audition yeah i always love a
good snl audition story
it's 1982.
me and jim belushi
is it no is john which one was honest
it's josh josh josh volusia jason jason
mamoa when he was on snow
um no yeah i mean there's not a ton to
it i i showcased in new york which is
like you do that in front of a crowd and
i just like brought my wigs which still
i'm like did i need the wigs you know
because i do all these like southern
characters too that was before tj mack
even
did he exist yeah this was like this
past fall tj mac is relatively new but
um i like showcase in front of a crowd
and not to to my own horn but it was
like it was awesome i was like oh [ __ ] i
just brought down the house and i
improved it i was like i had like a very
loose structure i was like man do this
character this character this but and
probably all the people that were there
were like we could tell you improv that
actually wasn't that good
how did the showcase get set up that's
like you submit yeah so that's like
right through my agents i think i said
like hey let's try because i had tested
it for snl in 2015. and then this year
i'd done all this character stuff on on
instagram and tick tock so i was like
let's try again for snl this year and
they're like put together something for
us to send to them and i literally just
threw together like 10 of my tick tock
videos and i just sent that and then
they they flew me up to the to the
showcase right which was awesome wow
yeah yeah so it was you know private jet
no i'm just kidding coach definitely
coach but uh yeah so then i i do the
showcase and then i i could feel i was
like okay i think that was great colin
jost is that how you say his last name
he said some very nice words to me after
the thing he was like colin yeah colin
jeff was like
um
he was like you know great that was so
great and whatever and he's so he was
just so sweet and so i i had a feeling i
was like i think i'm coming back for the
real test um and so then you know half a
week goes by my agent's call they're
like you're going to the real test so
then i fly up for the
the test and it's this whole thing and i
had done it back in 2015 where they put
you up in a specific hotel and there's
all this kind of
ritual to it you know and i think it
makes sense because
they know all these people want it so
bad and they've got to be very
systematic because
i don't know i mean i don't know their
mentality but it's just like it's a
system you know they just want to they
want to kind of dryly see everybody not
be influenced by too much anything
outside of the audition and then decide
based on that what does it entail the
test like
you just go up on this stage in front of
lauren and a variety of other people
usually
i feel like it's like around 10 people
you're on that snl stage that you always
see them waving from at the end of every
week you know it like looks like sesame
street or something yeah it is sesame
actually it's on sesame street the test
um that's a joke
[Laughter]
um but yeah yeah you you go up on that
stage and you audition in front of
lauren michaels in them i you can kind
of do whatever you want i hear pete
davidson just did stand up yeah i did
like six seven characters something and
i improv them but you know the famous
thing is they don't laugh but i think
they do laugh they think it's funny and
they just didn't i don't know they it
was like i had i felt like i'd brought
down the house at the showcase the week
before so i was like i'm gonna go up
there and improv you know in front of
these and i like got up and i remember i
was like i like i like to identify my
crowd you know i like to yeah okay and i
literally i was like hey there's lauren
there's no no there's donna i don't know
i even thought that would be cute or
something but it's like the reactions
are just like we don't need this just do
your thing and so i did it to just just
to not a lot of laughs and i basically
thought i bombed it and and in that case
you're like i bombed it because i
improvised it like i should have
prepared something i should have written
something you know and then i got off
the stage and then i was like i bombed
it i was depressed the whole night and
my boyfriend was like baby it's okay you
know and then and then i get a text like
in the middle of the night like they
want to meet you tomorrow at the
at the offices and so then you go meet
all the writers and everything at that
point you were like i got it uh exactly
yeah and that's the really sad thing
because
i think there were eight people at that
stage and then like three of us got it
and i was not one of them but that's the
whole story so you went and met the
writers like at the office yeah yeah i
met all the people and they're all so
great and a lot of them had already
known my stuff and it was just a great
day it was like a literally a fun day of
chatting and i've even worked with some
of those people since on other jobs and
it's been awesome but i didn't meet
lauren and most of the people met lauren
including the people that got it and at
the end of that day when they were like
all right you guys are going to go home
and i was like i didn't meet lauren
michaels i was like okay i didn't get it
and then you know there's two weeks of
all your friends being like that doesn't
mean anything maybe maybe and i was like
i think it did you know
i don't get the job and i'm like i was
right
that's it but it's great i mean it's a
very it's a very like magical thing to
be flown up there and do it and i'm
grateful for it and it's a long list of
people that
didn't get it you know i think like zach
galifianakis steve carell damn you know
all these people wow i've tested and not
gotten it so that's sick though so i
could still succeed in life you know no
i mean isn't it weird how you can make
some [ __ ] and just not think about it
and then
that weirdly becomes like the starting
point for a lot of people to know you
yeah yeah it's the strangest [ __ ] ever
yeah but it's just crazy because you
think back to like i still get the
[ __ ] yo you're the skinny penis guy
because i just made some stupid vine
where i said hey oh it's your boy skinny
penis
and to this day like there are still
people that message me and go i've been
watching your podcast for years and my
roommate finally realized you're the
skinny penis guy yeah yeah yeah and it's
like that's so crazy to me because that
was just some [ __ ] i just said yeah off
the cuff and now that's just it's
stamped in people's mind yeah some some
girl this weekend i uh i did a half
marathon i was like hanging around like
the finish line or whatever and this
girl comes out and she's like holy [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] guy from vine
and i was like
yup
that's me and she's like what's your
name again
and i was like josh momoa it was like so
demeaning to yeah joshua what's your
name again yeah yeah sort of meaning to
introduce yourself when they were the
ones that started the [ __ ]
conversation
what's your name yeah yeah yeah cody
cody what
and i was like
cody co and she was like
[ __ ]
oh
i'm sorry this is really cool it's just
been so long did you get a picture you
should check out the stuff i'm doing now
for the last six years you know do you
guys do you guys ever get the thing
where they're like i've met you and
you're like no i don't think we have and
they're like yes i don't know where from
but i've met you at a bar or something
yeah and you're like i don't think we've
met and i don't know how to tell you why
you think we've met yeah yeah they're
just and i think i did it once i was
like
you know me from from stuff that i've
made or from tv or something and they're
like no i don't yeah it's like okay
yeah exactly you're like okay mr hot
shot yeah i haven't all right yeah yeah
what tv show do i know you from will and
grace
yeah then they turn to stone
you just blow them
dissolve
for whatever reason people don't believe
it's me in person and so recently i've
had a lot of people like
stand maybe like 15 feet away and
they're just like
it's like another breath he can't be
that short yeah yeah yeah there's no
[ __ ] way that's literally probably
what they're saying they play the short
king song
it is interesting how like people they
don't put stuff together that much like
i i like you guys have started to get
acquainted with people being like oh i
know you from this other thing way back
and you're just like okay that's like
they don't
it's few people that are synthesizing
your whole body of work yeah and that's
great i think about that with like
regular actors too it's like you might
see like julia roberts and be like
you're from pretty woman and she's like
i have done so many movies yeah yeah
especially like internationally when
they can't get their films for like
several years
you're the guy from titanic
yeah leo's like what the [ __ ] yeah i
heard that in
20 years no you when you died man that
[ __ ] killed me i was wondering where the
level is where people start having to
just have security everywhere because
like leonardo dicaprio can't just go to
a bar right yeah whoa i saw him at john
and vinnie's you really did yeah just
out he was out with a couple of his
friends his friends were in black suits
with like likes yeah yeah yeah there was
like 12 of them
they were an armored car
yeah he was always some buzz i don't
know everyone was playing sunglasses
they weren't talking for some reason
kind of a weird friend group dynamic but
yeah they didn't say much from the
matrix they kind of kept looking
elsewhere but his eyes i don't know
super formal dinner yeah no no one was
allowed inside we were just looking
through the window but yeah he was out
he was just chilling yeah yeah dicks
put me in a headlock
yeah dragged me away yeah they kept
saying like who do you know here it's
like this is a restaurant dude
no [ __ ] i told you
yeah i've told this story before but
basically the our waitress was bugging
she's oh and then i was like who is that
she's like it's leo i'm like yeah he's
like a baseball player or something
right
just be like dad joke to the fullest
she just gets offended just does not
compute no she's like she like i rolled
me and then like walked away wow she was
like
and then
she's like it's people like you that
don't know who he is yeah
it's like what are you mad at me